[Applause]
James catches puts up the three Lego box
mystery toilet
[Applause]
but the officials are going to review
the same availables be mine
[Music]
Chris Bosh with the huge offensive
rebound
[Applause]
out of the game leads to the second shot
and clearly a three-point shot they
confirm that it was a three and the
Spurs had a chance to talk this over
Rose misses another Smith has it Knicks
down 3-2 the Bulls foul no Anthony for
trade that one goes down and the game is
tied
Newport on the drive out to Anthony
Smith or three-pointer way off the mark
Chandler tips it out again minutes will
reset down by two Mike Woodson not
calling timeout and I like that move in
the hands of Anthony Anthony for preto
remaining
there again you've got a 6-9 guy on here
he's a couple of feet again beyond the
arc for both teams hitting such big
shots Shumpert picks him up on the
switch they both fall down inside to
Noah Noah on the dribble back out to
Korver
final seconds Rose triples it off rolls
drive puts it up no good and the Knicks
win in overtime
what up thriller at Madison Square
Garden
Carmelo Anthony perhaps his finest
moment as a Knick to clutch threes one
at the end of regulation one on the
final seconds of overtime looking finds
Rhodes Rhodes trying to get open fires
away
I think my teammates
[Music]
[Applause]
so forth before crying
chess that's the three
[Applause]
Iguodala they do have a timeout decide
not to use a curry way downtown
oh [ __ ] from curry with six tension
second remaining
the brilliance chilling of Stefan curry
continues and he ties the NBA record
with his twelfth three-pointer of the
game
[Applause]
Westbrook gets off a decent look the
banker and you've got to press up
roberson just a little late but that's
just the man that's about 35 feet out
well beyond the 28 foot mark
[Applause]
amazing here at the Air Canada center
five tenths of a second remaining
Linsanity continues and the Raptors team
have believed their luck they had the
Lakers down Kobe with the dagger and
pulverizing them straight on with you
Jeremy Lin with a clutch three-pointer
he now has 27